hey everyone this is kevin from
thechesswebsite.com and today we're
going to be going over the chebanenko
slav so if you are
playing as black and you like to play
the slav against the queen's gambit
or if you're white and you like to play
the queen's game and you run into the
slav i think this video is going to be
very informative if you're not familiar
with this lob starts out with
the queen's game it with d4 d5 and then
c4 here giving up this pawn if black
wants it but the sloth says we're going
to decline that here with
c6 and then white's usually playing
knight to f3
knight to f6 here and then knight to c3
and sometimes
they may change the the order of these
they could bring their knight out
to c3 first but usually this is the
setup that we're going
to see and then from black standpoint in
the champion inkoslav
black plays the move pawn to a
six now i do have other videos if you
want to watch on just the sloth itself
if you want to look at the semislav you
can look at those but
in today's video we're going to be
looking at a6 and all the variations
that black may run into and some of the
common themes that black's going to be
looking for
in this particular opening now from here
uh white may continue with the the main
idea and that is to play pawn here to e3
solidifying this pawn chain opening up
for the light square bishop to get
involved they can castle on the king
side right away
and black's going to push forward here
on the queen side part of the reason
that they play this pawn
to a6 is to push forward here with b5
now normally without this pawn here on
b5
white's really looking for an exchange
here so pawn takes here on c4
and now that the light squared bishop is
available to come into the action white
can take this
pawn here on c4 and develop material at
the same time
getting ready to castle on the king side
this usually ends up as a very good
exchange for whites
because they're able to do so many
things at the same time
that's so much the case when the pawn is
here
on b5 because if flack's able to capture
this pawn right here on a c4
the white bishop can't take here because
it's defended by the pawn here on
b5 so they could decide well let's go
ahead and just defend this with pawn to
b3 they could also
just push forward here c5 some players
as soon as they see this material
they open up with the d6 and b6 squares
and just push forward with
c5 and they can also make a mistake they
can play bishop to
d3 because this is pretty common if
the pawn hasn't taken around c4 this
would be a big mistake it's very
different when the pawn is here on b5 so
we'll look at those
three variations first the first one
being pawn here to
b3 black plays bishop here to f5 uh one
of the things that black wants to do is
get the light square bishop involved
into the game
before they kind of block off the pawn
chain here
with e6 now white could start to just
take material here
if they take let's say pawn takes here
on
b5 then pawn takes here and then really
white needs to play pawn to a4
they can't let black just completely
dominate the queen side of the board
but then black can just push forward
here with b4 then it comes back here to
e2
and then pawn to e6 you can see black
has a
very good setup here eventually we want
to take control of this
open c file but can get the dark square
bishop involved into the game
this knight here on e2 is blocking this
bishop here on f1 it's going to be very
difficult to castle on the king side
anytime soon
and white's not going to be castling to
the queen side anytime
soon either if we come back maybe they
don't take that pawn here on b5 they
could always try and capture
the pawn here on d5 black's just going
to capture right here
maybe bishop d2 preparing the castle on
the king side looking at their options
here
but then pawn to e6 again very solid
setup
from black in this position if they
don't take they could just decide let's
go ahead and push forward here
with c5 anytime you see c5 and you'll
see this through a few variations that
we'll look at today
i pretty much am always going to be
playing night here to
see or excuse me to d7 this sets up a
couple things but it also
stops this knight coming here to e5
black can also push forward with e5 at
some point
this pawn here on d4 it starts to get
overloaded controlling this e5 square as
well as defending this c5 square
and so this knight coming here to d7
allows me to push forward here at e5
and put a lot of pressure on my opponent
now in this case if we do play that
knight to d7
i don't think they have tons of great
options here although they could just
play bishop here to e2
castle on the king side i think that's
fine for them
if they don't play pawn to c5 they could
also just play
knight to e5 in this case i really like
attacking on
the king side this knight right here yes
it's attacking this pawn here on c6
so this night on b8 is gonna have to
stay at home
and defend this for a while but i think
black can really start to push on
the king side of the board you can see
the queen side for both sides completely
extended up the board the pawns are not
adding any layer of protection to the
king
so i say let's go on the offensive here
and play pawn to h5
uh maybe they play maybe they're they're
bishop
to maybe b2 i think that's fine but then
we can just play e6
uh get our dark square bishop into the
game if we want to we can still
castle but i do think we have a very
strong attack here
on the king side if we wanted to so
that's what it looks like if the pawn
comes here to
b3 but they could not they could just
play pawn to c5 and just say i don't
want to worry about the c4 square at all
that's fine anytime we see that c5 you
already know we're going to be playing
knight here to d7
and just you can kind of see what this
would look like we are worried
at some point about this knight to e5
and this
knight here on d7 protects that because
we could just take right here
pawn takes and then knight comes back
here to d7 attacking both of these pawns
here on
c5 and e5 uh black should have
a pretty good game from there can always
play pawn to e6
in the future get your dark square
bishop involved into
the game if they don't play knight to e5
i don't think they would after we played
knight to d7 if they play you know
bishop to e2
now we can start to fianchetto on the
king side of the board play pawn
two g6 if they castle we play bishop
here to
g7 now coming back they can also make
mistakes because some people have never
heard or seen the chevy ninja slav
and so once you play this pawn to
b5 they could play bishop here to d3
because they're used to you taking here
on c4 eventually
and then they just take here yes they
lost a tempo because they lost they
moved their bishop twice
uh but this is just how they play not
recognizing that okay this is very
different because they can't just take
the pawn here
because then their bishop is going to
fall so as soon as
they play bishop to d3 you are going to
take with your pawn and then the
bishop's just going to fall back here to
e2
you play e6 and you are now up a
pawn in material so that's what we're
looking at
if they play that e3 early on
in the opening they don't have to play
e3 another variation you could see is
queen to
b3 and this just really says hey if
you're going to be playing that bishop
here to
f5 which we definitely are and
at some time then queen to b3
is attacking this pawn here on b7 now
the nice thing about
the japanese slav is it gives more
variations
on ways you can defend this pawn because
you can even play rook here to
a7 at some point to protect this pawn if
you really wanted to get your
light square bishop involved into the
game but in this case they play queen to
b3
we are just going to be taking this
material here on a c4
they're gonna take with their queen and
then we're gonna be pushing forward here
to
b5 i always like to play variations
where
i can put my opponent in a tough spot
that if they haven't seen it before they
can definitely make a huge mistake and i
can go on to an easy victory but even if
they don't i still have a very very
solid structure
and that's what i think pawn to b5 does
because they still may want to keep
their queen
very involved into the game they may not
want to just come back to
queen to e3 and so they could look at it
and say okay queen two b4
it's still definitely in the mix but
this definitely is going to be a
very very bad move because of the move
pawn to
e5 and you can see that the queen
is starting to get trapped here there's
no actual good squares for it to go to
it can't stay on this dark square
diagonal it can't come here to
a5 it would be captured by the queen
here the only safe square it can come to
is b3 now white can take here with the
pawn here on
d4 attacking the knight here on c3
this knight doesn't have any good
options as well would really love to
come here to e4 but that's being
defended by
the knights on f6 so really it can come
back to
d1 or b1 uh so maybe d1 just because
they feel like okay it started on b1 so
i have to feel good about myself let's
bring it back here to d1
but then bishop here to e6 attacking the
queen maybe queen comes back here to c2
pawn up here to c5
and you can start to see there's a lot
of pressure coming against white here
yes black is up a pawn in material here
uh but definitely feels like black is
controlling things pond
white has no pawns pushed forward at all
black is completely controlling the
queen side of the board
and doesn't have any room to really get
the other pieces involved into the game
so this would be a
a huge mistake but even if they don't
take
or come here to b4 i think that's fine
because you know queen to d3 makes a lot
of sense drop it back stay centralized
still involvement of the action
from here black just plays pawn to e6
solid structure on the king side
preparing to get your dark square bishop
involved into the game
maybe pawn to e4 trying to control the
center of the board here
bishop to b7 and you can start to
counter attack at the center of the
board from the wings here you can even
fianchetto to the king side as well
since they do have the two central pawns
both sides equal in material here but
you are going to have to counter attack
by you know bring your bishops to the
side and attacking
that way the last variation we are going
to look at is if they play
pawn to c5 they say i just don't even
want to worry about this c4
square so i'm just going to push forward
right here anytime we see c5 you should
know by now we're going to be playing
knight here to
d7 now they could play pawn to e3 i
think this makes logical sense for them
solidifying this long pawn shade here
opening up for the light square bishop
to go anywhere they want castle on the
king side
but the problem is we can really chip
away at the center of the board by
playing pawn to e5
and they may think okay well i have a
pawn and a knight
attacking this square here and black
only has
a knight so why would they ever play e5
but after they take right here we can
play the move
knight to e4 and
you can start to see when if they take
right here we're going to capture with
our pawn attacking the knight and the
knight
is the lone defender of this pawn here
on e5 so if they play the move
knight to d4 well now we can take here
on e5 and
it also allows us to at some point
play bishop takes here on c5 and we can
castle on the king side if we want to
if they want to attack this pawn that's
fine they could play knight to
d2 but then we played knight takes on
c5 reason we take it this time on c5 is
because this
knight is now defending this pawn here
on e4
and you can see this knight here on d2
it's blocking off this dark square
bishop from defending this pawn here
and you can see this queen here on d8 is
definitely a threat so if they wanted to
exchange queens off the board
we could make that happen for them but
also we have an outpost coming up here
on knight
2 d3 check if we wanted to add some
extra pressure on our opponent as well
we can also get our light square bishop
involved and put some additional
pressure on them
that way now they may not take uh
with their or they may not play that
pawn to
e3 another option that they could have
is to get their dark square bishop
involved into the game much like we want
to get our light square bishop involved
into the game
before we play pawn to e6 they might get
their dark square bishop involved into
the game before they play that pawn
2 e3 in this case i recommend playing
knight 2 h5 attacking the bishop
i think the bishop may just come back to
like d2 it doesn't make any sense to me
to come back to c1 but maybe
bishop to d2 makes them feel good about
themselves that they have now got their
bishop involved into the game and now we
can play pawn to g6 preparing to
fianchetto to
the king side of the board i think
that's fine but also gives them an
opportunity maybe they feel like this is
a great outpost
bishop here to uh e5 yes it may be
tempting to go and take with your knight
but i recommend just playing pawn
to f6 uh maybe they bring their bishop
back here to
g3 now and then we can push forward here
with e5
and you can start to see black really
has
the center control here and all their
pieces are working
in unison now if they don't bring their
bishop out they could
also play the move queen to c2
in this case we can just play pawn to e5
that queen on
c2 is not defending these dark squares
in the center of the board here
so if they take we can now play and met
up here to
g4 uh this is not only
attacking this pawn from this knight but
also this knight as well
and this bishop here on f8 is also
attacking this pawn here on c5 so black
is going to get that pawn back in
material
maybe they played knight to a4 to
protect this pawn
that's fine we can just come back and
take this pawn here
on uh e5 so that is the chebadenko slav
hopefully you guys
enjoyed this video if you did if you
wouldn't mind
please hitting that like button
definitely supports the channel lets me
know that you like these type of videos
but thank you so much for the support
thanks for watching and i'll see you
guys in the next video